Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
DC dropped is Justice League
Crisis on Infinite Earths movie trailer.
So we'll break it all down.
There's a bunch of stuff going on here.
it's actually going to be a three part movie.
This is just for part one
because the crisis storyline is so big.
Thankfully, they're not trying to cram
it all like delete a bunch of stuff
just to fit it into a single movie.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I'll probably give away a couple of copies
when it releases in January.
This is coming out in January.
doesn't this all feels so familiar?
Like didn't
we have a version of crisis on Infinite Earths?
yeah, that's right. They did that in the arrowverse.
one of my favorite
tropes of that
is that Oliver Queen Green Arrow was always blaming
anything bad that happened at all for any reason,
even if it was on a big cosmic scale
like crisis on infinite Earths,
on something that the Flash did like.
Barry, what have you done this time to be there,
the flash was to blame
for a lot of the mishaps
that they had in their big crossovers each year.
But this version of crisis on infinite Earths.
Even though I am expecting a bunch of cameos
and Easter eggs is mostly based on the tomorrow
versus line of continuity in the animated movies,
which is everything that started
with the Superman Man of Tomorrow movie,
which itself was based on a reboot
that came out of the Justice League Apocalypse
War movie so this Crisis on Infinite Earths
three part movie is meant to spin directly
out of the events of Justice League Warworld,
which is like the movie that just came out
with these versions of the characters, that means
Jensen Ackles version of Batman Darren Chris's
version of Superman from Superman, Man of Tomorrow.
A lot of the other animated movies recently that's why
there's all this footage of the Legion of Super-Heroes
with what looks like Brainiac five from
the recent Legion of Super-Heroes movie with Supergirl.
so this version of crisis on Infinite Earths
is basically meant to do for the tomorrow verse
what Justice League Apocalypse
War did for the previous DC animated universe?
And those versions of the characters basically serve
as like a big bookend for that line of continuity
as they reboot and start with like a brand new line
of continuity, a brand new animation style.
as you probably notice,
the animation style of this movie
is in the style of the tomorrow verse
line of animated movies.
So part of the idea here is that the DC animated movies
want to like completely change
their animation style, introduce some new versions
of the characters doing the voice acting
So they're basically trying to write that canonically
into the story like, they're rebooting the universe.
Like things will change the way
that things were rebooted during the comic book Crisis
on Infinite Earths.
And that's why when they come back
with a brand new line of continuity,
all the actors sound different
and everything looks different.
it's really clever way for movie studios
to generally just reboot stuff that's going on.
They're kind of doing the same thing in the Marvel
Universe right now with Avengers Secret Wars.
That'll serve as like a soft reboot in
they might recast a couple of the characters.
It won't be quite as big a reboot
but it's the same basic principle like Kevin Feige
over in the Marvel
Universe wants to tie up a lot of loose ends.
like right now over at Marvel, it's
kind of a mess of all this old stuff
that they want to reboot into the new stuff.
They have new versions of X-Men
characters, new Fantastic Four characters.
They want to introduce it, if you remember before James
Gunn was hired to come run DC
and did his big reboot into the DCU,
which is going to be happening with Superman Legacy
in 2025 originally the new live action
DC movies were actually building up.
It was like a ten year plan for a Crisis on Infinite
Earths movie in the live action Justice League movies.
that would have been like Henry Cavill's
version of Superman, Ben Affleck's Batman gal
Gaydos, Wonder Woman, Jason Momoa, Aquaman,
all those characters basically,
Zack Snyder had his own Justice League trilogy,
but that wasn't going to be Crisis on Infinite Earths.
I've already done a much bigger video about that,
so I'll link it. Baloney.
The description.
He's already detailed what the plot of his Justice
League Two and Justice League three were going to be.
The interesting connection, though,
is that the events of Zack Snyder's Justice League
trilogy are actually fairly similar to the events
of the animated Justice League apocalypse war movie.
I don't know if that's on purpose
or just a coincidence, but But I'm sure there were
a couple of people behind the scenes when they were
making Justice League apocalypse or who were like,
you know what?
They're not going to do those live action
Justice League sequels.
Maybe we should use some of those ideas
for our animated movie
that we're going to use to reboot our animated universe
Funny how that all winds up
working out behind the scenes, but just starting.
At the beginning of the footage
in all of these trailers here
you see some of the changes to the original crisis
storyline from the comics.
A lot of the same character bits are still there,
but obviously they're all basing
this on what they've done before.
In the Tomorrow verse movies like Justice
League Warworld we see their version of The Monitor
coming to warn them about the coming crisis,
whether it's going to obliterate the multiverse
inside the tomorrow verse with that version
of the Justice League from the War World movie
in a bunch of other characters that it's collected
from across that version of the multiverse.
They focus primarily on the Flash's
point of view from the trailer.
In the main Justice League universe, they kind of
did something similar with the ending of the Justice
League apocalypse war, ending with the Flash,
going back to reboot that version of the timeline.
just because the Flash works so well as a POV character
in a storyline like Crisis on Infinite Earths
because of his abilities,
he can travel across all these other universes,
whether on purpose or by accident,
and see what's happening with the crisis waves.
as we see in the trailer several times,
like he's traveling across multiple different universes
they're couple of scenes where he genuinely looks
surprised to see the crime syndicate
on Earth three in other alternate Earth
where he's visiting a version of the Justice League
that's just being formed as opposed to his version
which has existed for a while.
Like what's what's going on here?
some of the other characters
that the monitor grabs from other universes
include versions of Vixen,
Green Arrow, Jon Stewart, Green Lantern.
Not all of them were probably on this main version
of the Justice League, but they're just other heroes
that are active in these universes.
this looks like a version of Dick Grayson, Robin.
But he's an adult.
Like, he looks like he's stayed Robin
and did not become Nightwing.
Speaking to this version of Huntress
they're a couple more crime syndicate characters
like Ultraman Lois Lane.
Superwoman.
This looks like Zatanna in a version of Captain Adam
from another universe.
Maybe some justice society characters involved too.
this version of Supergirl is the one from the Tomorrow
version, the Legion of Super-Heroes movie
that happened a little while ago.
Not sure what the shadow Creatures are.
The Jensen Ackles Batman is fighting Maybe something
to do with the Anti-Monitor during the movie
we see a couple of crisis waves destroying
different universes, just like in the comics.
maybe this character from the other universe
with the egg on his chest
is another version of Captain Atom or a Green Arrow
or Jon Stewart Green Lantern.
he has the egg on his chest.
So my assumption would be a four green arrow.
But we'll see.
weirdly, they have not released
the actual cast list breakdown of who
all the characters are going to be in the movie
when they're on the Watchers cosmic base.
In seeing this cosmic scene of all the different
universes being destroyed in real time
with the crisis wave from the back, you can spot
versions of Red Tornado in his signature cave.
This is the Tara's. The Tanners father can't quite do.
Some of the other characters in front of them are
When they switch perspectives, we see another version
of Vixen, two versions of Superman.
You can actually tell the difference
because their belts are a little bit
different in the symbol on their belts
are a little bit different.
this is just a wide shot of the monitors base after
he's assembled, everyone with everybody freaking out.
they're couple more crime
syndicate characters who seem like the flash meets
or he accidentally runs into them
and they try to stop him thinking that he's a villain.
remember in Earth three on the crime syndicate's Earth,
they believe that they're heroes.
In all the regular heroes are actually the villains.
we also see their version of our man
in their version of Jon Stewart.
It looks like Then we see their Lois Lane Superwoman,
capturing the Flash with her lasso of truth.
this is also Crime Syndicate Flash.
His name is Johnny Quick a.k.a Johnny Allen.
this is just another scene of Brainiac five
in the Legion of Super-Heroes explaining the crisis.
Wave to Supergirl
like it's destroying all these different universes.
They have a different looking version of The Harbinger,
who works for the Monitor.
We saw a version that in the arrowverse
that actually wound up being Lila
Because she was originally based on the character
who became the Harbinger character.
So they just kind of used her for Harbinger when
they got to their version of Crisis on Infinite Earths.
It just kind of worked out that way.
this actually looks like the wedding of Barry Allen
and his version of Iris West.
Like things start going down
while their wedding is actually happening.
Martian Manhunter is here,
Jensen, Ackles, Batman all over the place.
Of course, generally looks about as crazy as you would
expect for a version of crisis on Infinite Earths.
I am a little sad that we won't see the version
that they plan in the live action movies.
James Gunn's DCU is obviously doing its own version
of a build up in Justice League movies,
but I don't think that he's planning
on doing a crisis on Infinite Earths movie now.
Whatever his brand new Justice
League trilogy is going to build up towards in
the next like ten years or so, it's
going to be like a completely different type of event.
the interesting thing,
though, is that when he was teasing his big reboot,
like way early
on, he said he was making plans, quote unquote.
He used a picture from Justice League Kingdom come.
so. Maybe his Justice League movies
will start by adapting versions of Kingdom Come.
I think that's kind of what he's going for.
Like he wants his movies to feel very different
from all the ideas
that people had before, since they were working up
to crisis on Infinite Earths before.
Like that's
what the Flash movie was getting ready to set up
until obviously they rebooted everything
and then changed the ending of that movie.
so when James Gunn came along,
they probably told him what their plans were.
And he's like,
okay, well, we're going to change everything.
Let's really change it most.
So it just is a feel like a rehash
of all the stuff that people were doing before
I did a couple videos about this too.
There are a bunch of deleted scenes
from the end of the Flash movie that were originally
meant to set up things that obviously now
James Gunn does not intend to pay off,
primarily with Henry Cavill's version of Superman
in that version of the Justice League
they were going to be a couple scenes at the end of
that movie were like Henry Cavill, Superman film,
the couple of cameo scenes like he actually filmed
the brand new scenes for that movie that they
then had to remove, were basically appeared to bury in
the speed force and warned him about a coming crisis.
Ben Affleck's Batman, who did appear in that movie,
also wound up at the end of the movie
getting lost into the multiverse,
like he disappeared into the multiverse
and would reappear as part of this crisis
storyline in the movies.
That's how they were going to explain the original
ending of The Flash movie, where basically
the Flash comes back changing a couple of things,
and he winds up changing it
so that Michael Keaton's Batman ends up replacing
Ben Affleck's Batman on the main Earth.
And Supergirl also winds up on the main earth
with Henry Cavill Superman, too, In all of them
meeting him at the courthouse when he comes out
after his father is freed from prison.
that's why at the end of the theatrical cut,
he comes out, he sees George Clooney's Batman.
Like, originally
the ending was going to be completely different.
They filmed a whole bunch of scenes
with Michael Keaton's
Batman, Supergirl, Henry Cavill Superman,
showing up in meeting with her.
I did a much longer video about all those
deleted scenes to all link that at the end of this
But in the live action stuff,
they just made a bunch of big announcements
about Superman Legacy,
who the character is going to be like,
the new version of Lex Luthor,
What's going on with the new version of Superman?
What the plot is going to be.
I just did a bunch of videos for that too.
You can click here to learn about that in click here
for all those Flash movie in Superman deleted scenes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!